all right treasury secretary Janet
Yellen is prepping for her big trip to
Beijing this week I bet that has Xi
Jinping Running Scared listen to How
strong she is against one of our
greatest adversaries we seek a healthy
economic relationship with China a
growing China that plays by
International rules is good for the
United States and the world
that's right you tell them Janet China
won't take advantage of us at all with
that attitude CIA director William Burns
wanted to get in the mix too this
weekend jumping on the globalist de-risk
and diversify bandwagon listen to this
no country wants to find itself at the
mercy of a cartel of one for critical
minerals and Technologies the answer to
that is not to decouple from an economy
like China's which would be foolish but
to sensibly de-risk and diversify by
securing resilient Supply chains
protecting our technological Edge and
investing in industrial capacity
thank you
all right joining me now is Gordon Chang
senior fellow at the Gatestone Institute
all right Gordon he says it's foolish to
decouple you heard the treasury
secretary you heard the CIA director
what's your take on it
well first of all you know China is
declared a people's war on the U.S and
although we're Americans we think that
we have the right to be oblivious about
what our enemies say about us that
phrase has great meaning for the
Communist party and they're serious
about it and they are running an
unrestricted Warfare campaign against us
which means that we should not be
funding them with for instance our trade
with China or with our investments into
Chinese companies because those
Investments go straight to the military
in many cases and the technology gets
pipelined to the people's Liberation
Army so I I don't care what term you use
but we definitely need to decouple
because it's morally and strategically
wrong to support a country that is
configuring its military to kill
Americans
and and this is the big concern about
Biden and taking what is now reportedly
potentially up to 40 million dollars not
all from China but still uh millions of
dollars from China potentially
compromising our Our National
Intelligence operations
um but I I want to to get your take on
something uh very specific here the
number of Chinese Nationals account
encountered by the United States border
patrol it's exploding for the 2020
fiscal year it was just 342. but for
this fiscal year it's already over 12
000 that they have encountered Chinese
Nationals encounter by Border Patrol
coming across our Southern border what's
going on here
first of all China's in distress so the
Chinese people are trying to get out of
their country it's extreme pessimism and
really a failure of society but in that
number Jason
um there are males of military age
unaccompanied by family members
pretending not to speak English
traveling in packs of between 5 and 15.
and those almost certainly are the
saboteurs they're being placed in the
United States because on the first day
of a war with Asia I believe that they
will commit acts of sabotage against us
and the bide Administration is not
tracking these people it's obvious
what's going on even the border patrol
has been able to find known links to the
Chinese military with some of these
people coming across the Biden
Administration couldn't care less
yeah there are reports that some of
these Chinese Nationals are wearing uh
camouflages they come across our
Southern border I'm sure they're just
you know looking for a better job uh but
uh some scary stuff happening there
Gordon Chang thank you so much for
joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else